Thanks everybody for coming. I just
want to introduce a Emma Yang. Uh,
she is a 14 year olds, a
ninth grade student, uh,
here in New York and she has been coding
since she was about six years old. Uh,
she's a multiple award winner
for various different things.
She is a published writer, which I
think she's going to tell you about.
And she's working on a new APP called
timeless, which is designed for a,
um,
uh,
Alzheimer's patients to be able to
live a little bit more independently.
So I'm just gonna, um,
without further ado, Emma.
Thank you.
Hi.
So my name is Emma Yang.
I'm 14 years old and a freshman in
high school and I'm also the founder of
timeless. So a bit about
myself. I love to bike.
I also love cats, but my family can't
have a cat because we travel a lot.
So I imagine that I'm a cat and
a Volvo. I love to code. Uh,
but that wasn't how everything started.
I actually was never groomed
to be a math or a tech was.
My mom always wanted me
to be a writer. Um, we,
I'm from like a house full of
engineers and mathematicians.
So we needed a historian or a writer, she
said, and that's how it was initially.
Um, here is a video of me at
a book launch reading a book.
I was published in [inaudible]
and Emma will be reading the
diary, a hobby, the rabbit.
I'm happy as a parent
and the garden to the other
side of the forest to play.
We played tag was
back to my house to have lunch.
I introduced to my family.
I was happened to
thank you.
So that was what I was
around five or six years old.
I was quite a writer and my work was
actually published in a couple of books
that are still being sold in Hong Kong.
Then one day my dad put me in front
of a computer and showed me scratch,
which is where you can drag
and drop different blocks
of code to make a program.
And I instantly fell in love with
it and I was coding with an hour's.
I was amazed by the extraordinary range
of things you could do with a couple of
blocks of code. It didn't matter whether
it is an application, a game or tool,
a w whether it was simple or complex.
It was my own personal creation that
was unique and special and that I could
share with the rest of the world.
This is what motivated me to progress.
They're building websites,
mobile apps and more.
Then in the summer of 2015 when
I was around 11 years old, I uh,
participated in something called
the technovation challenge,
which is a girls'
entrepreneurship technology,
a competition that encourages
girls to pursue stem.
I developed an APP called
Concussion Checker,
which is an easy way for
people to evaluate head injury.
So the possibility of concussion
developing this APP and the company
business plan for the competition was my
springboard into a whole different level
of technology using tech to help my
community and solve real world problems.
I realized that even though I was 11
years old and a middle school student,
I could create apps,
products that had meaningful
functionalities to impact
and benefit people from
around the world.
We got to the finals,
we went to San Francisco and
won second place globally.
Even though receiving the
award was a really amazing,
it was the discovery of a whole
community of girls and women who had
groundbreaking ideas that could change
the world that I cherish the most.
It changed my entire perspective.
Yeah.
This is my grandma when I was
around seven or eight years old.
She forgot my birthday, but we thought
she was just being a little forgetful,
but then she forgot how old I was,
what she had just had for dinner,
how would turn the TV.
She lost track of time and so much more.
Some of the common difficulties
faced by Alzheimer's patients.
My grandma is not alone.
There are 50 million people worldwide
who suffer from Alzheimer's.
By 2050 that number is expected
to rise to 130 million.
Prevalence is on the rise,
but there is no cure.
Yeah,
like my grandmother,
people who have Alzheimer's often
have difficulty remembering events,
taking a new information,
recognizing people and places
and separating fact from fiction.
Okay,
so as the disease progressed,
we would set up visual aids
around my grandma's house to help.
Remember we continued to send her photos
of us and hopes that she remember us
for as long as possible to what you see
here on the right is a picture of the
whiteboard that we put in
my grandma's living room.
Where you have on top is my dad's phone
number and the middle is the phone
number of the person she needs
to visit as well as the address.
And on the bottom it
says Sunday in Chinese,
which is the day that those taken on.
On the left you have the iPad that she
uses to look at the photos that we sent
her.
And so as time went by I started to wonder
whether there is a simple mobile app
that could help my grandmother and
other Alzheimer's patients or dementia
patients to remember events,
stay engaged with friends and family,
and to recognize the people around them
in the same way that all of the things
we set up for her would help her remember.
So research suggests that stimulating
one's memory and socializing,
especially by using a mobile app or a
computer, can actually help to stay, uh,
to stay, engage with loved ones and look
at photos can actually help to slow down
cognitive decline.
Okay.
So my family hunted extensively for such
an APP that we were sure must exist,
but we came away disappointed
because in fact it didn't.
There are many tools out there,
but none of them actually help patients
improve their daily lives. In fact,
in general,
I'm very few apps are developed for the
elderly due to the stereotype that's old
people can't use technology.
So right around that time I started
learning how to code with swift and Ios
programming language.
So I took the matter into my own
hands and developed timeless.
So what is timeless?
Timeless is a first of its kind.
Caregiver assisted a simple APP for
Alzheimer's patients to help them remember
events, stay in connected and
engaged the friends and family,
and to help them recognize the people
around them using artificial intelligence,
space to facial recognition technology.
It addresses all of the challenge faced
by Alzheimer's patients in one single
tool.
So there are four phase one core features
for updates, helps patients stay,
engage with loved ones by showing a stream
of photos sent by friends and family
through a timeless.
Each of the photos are tagged with the
names and relationships with the people
to help the patient
stimulate their memory.
Today is simplified daily information
and events to help the patient manage so
do the lives.
Contacts is a picture phone book that
helps patients to contact their friends
and family by simply tapping on call
or text without having to remember any
phone numbers.
Then finally identify is where the
patient can use the photos at the phone's
camera to take a picture of someone's
face that's in real life or an actual
physical photo and timeless.
We use the Fisher recognition
to tell them who that is.
So let me show you a
quick demo of the APP.
Users sign into timeless.
You touch id or face id
passwords are not needed.
Once the patient logs in timeless,
bring us up to the home screen.
There are five main features I'll take
you through each one of them starting
with updates.
UPDATES is a feeder for central
Centrify friends and family.
Each of the photos is tagged with the
names of the people in the photos by
facial recognition.
Next is today,
which is a daily overview including the
date, whether and next event of the day.
This helps the patient remember
activities and appointments, photos.
She was pictures sent
by friends and family.
The photos are grouped by person by
facial recognition to help the patient
refresh their memory in recognize friends.
I learned them look at photos regularly.
Contacts helps patients who
have difficulty remembering
phone numbers and other
contact information.
The patient can simply tap on
call or cacs to contact someone.
Pamela's we'll all through remind the
patient at the same person that's been
called less than five minutes ago.
I can defy is the key feature of the APP.
Patients often have can have difficulty
recognizing the people around them. Well,
they identified the patient.
You'd take a picture of the person and
Thomas will use facial recognition to
recognize that
the APP is managed by the caregiver who
helps enter events into the patient's
calendar and invites friends and relatives
to join the patients. Timeless Circle
for friends and family sharing photos
with the patient is as easy as taking a
picture and sharing it with the chat.
I must works on both iPhones and iPads.
So what'd you saw in the demo video was
an app that was under development with
the support of expert partners such
as Doctor Melissa cramps who is an
Alzheimer's specialist at New York's
Pescetarian Lulea men Adreno who isn't
human experience designer and Kairos,
which is a human analytics
startup based in Miami.
A timeless has also gone
a lot of worldwide press
coverage from you at the u s
to Malaysia to Mexico to Spain and has
also garnered a really wide reach on
social media are demo video has reached
over 36,000 views and within a year.
And we've also gone overwhelming
feedback from Facebook and Twitter.
So the APP is currently under development
and we've recently revamped the UI to
make it more elderly friendly
and cutting up the front end.
And now I'm developing the back end and
should be completing the APP by the mid
this year.
So once phase one is completed,
I plan to roll out to pilot a pilot to
users to collect feedback and to continue
developing interface too.
So phase two would include
music gamification to allow
the paid caregivers to
ask the patient questions through
Trivia and games and also multilingual
capabilities in Spanish and Chinese.
So phase one is foundational.
Phase two is my short term goals,
but research also suggests that language
and mobile usage could help to predict
if someone showed signs of Alzheimer's.
So that brings us to one of my
longterm goals for timeless,
which is whether we can use timeless as
a research platform to collect data for
on mobile usage.
So by monitoring and tracking a non
Alzheimer's patient and an Alzheimer's
patient's activities, navigation,
eye movements and et Cetera,
we can actually maybe find
signs of Alzheimer's or we
could use machine learning
algorithms to detect Alzheimer's disease.
Earlier, the possibilities are endless.
Okay.
So my most pressing need right now is
to scale the development and to drive
adoption. The success of the APP depends
on how many people were able to help.
So Dr Carry Greenfield at
the Comprehensive Center
for Brainhealth and Florida
Atlantic University has agreed to give
feedback on the APP and also to be the
first site to offer the APP to its
patients. We need more of those sites.
I've also recently pushed
out a crowdfunding campaign
on Indiegogo to support
the continued development of timeless.
I'm a full time student so I
can't work on this all alone.
So the best way to scale and speed
of development is to collaborate with
developers to help to grow timeless.
So please help to spread
word about the campaign.
So Thomas has also been getting a lot of
media coverage and including in between
from Bill Gates that I got last Friday.
And so all this attention really attests
to how many people will benefit from
this.
And I'm so excited to see this develop
into something that will help so many
people in the Alzheimer's community.
So you can find out more about timeless,
uh,
on by following it on Facebook
and Twitter and also visiting its
website@timeless.care.
So a bit about me outside of timeless,
I'm also a mentee in the
wool from mentorships program
where I work with mentors
at wool from on machine learning
projects on using the Wolfram language.
So on the left is a picture of me that
I took with Dr. Steven Wolf from the
summer and I also represented Wolfrem
and the opportunity project run by the
White House.
So in the picture is Megan Smith,
the former CTO and Dj Patil
for the former data scientist.
So some of the projects I've also worked
on in the mentorships program include
using NYC open data to analyze collisions
and traffic data and also using
computer vision to identify
road signs. And also, er,
I'm right now I'm working on creating a
machine learning model for lung cancer
detection in CT scans.
Also at my school I've founded the
coding club and the middle school to
encourage girls to,
to get into stem and to code.
It's my small contribution
to stem advocacy for girls.
Okay.
And I'm still a writer.
I write now,
I'm writing for the quiet
revolution is quiet direst blog.
And my next piece is due to
be released on February 28th.
Okay.
Thank you so much for your time.
All right. So I think we're supposed
to do some question and answer. Um,
we've got some chairs over
there that I could get. So it,
so it's supposed to be more comfortable.
Oh, they're going to grab them for us.
So the way we do it at Google,
we call it a fireside chat.
So we're supposed to imagine that there's
a fire there and then we're going to
sit down and just have
this like relaxing chat.
So I'm going to ask you like the question
I always ask when somebody does a tech
demo is like,
does it actually work?
Okay.
Yeah. So, uh, as to
whether it works right now,
right now it's like under development.
So a lot of their stuff that you saw in
the video actually is the Ui works, but,
and also the facial recognition is live.
But you know,
part of what I'm raising money for is to,
you know,
continue that development
to its completion. But yeah.
So what would be the next
step in your development?
So right now it's to develop the
backend and then to really, um,
build a team of developers so that I can,
you know,
maintain the APP through it's released
when I at least it over the summer.
And then she kind of solicit feedback
from that because the reason why I reached
out to so many doctors and brain health
centers is to make sure that I can pilot
this with actual patients and their
caregivers and their families.
So once I solicit that feedback,
I'll be able to, you know,
improve on it and add
those phase two features.
Right. So it sounds like it, I mean, you
have a lot of the stuff already finished,
right? If the UI is there. Yeah. Um,
and you've got the facial recognition,
you did that with a partnership,
right?
Yeah, I just did that in
partnership was a Kairos,
which is the human elliptic startup
that they do facial recognition.
So I've been doing that in
partnership with them and, um,
they've also been a really great, you
know, technical mentor. Um, you know,
I reached out to them in the beginning
of this project and I was still lucky
that they actually got back to me and
become a long term mentor and with this
project.
Right.
That part is really interesting.
I read that story about you, um,
a couple of days ago. Yeah. But
the, the idea of you just, you,
you emailed this company that's
doing facial recognition technology.
Yeah. I emailed the, uh, the CTO of
the company and us. So, you know,
I'm the middle school coder who are
looking to do this project and we're jewel
be willing to, you know,
be my mentor and you know,
support me with the Fisher
recognition and machine learning side.
And they agreed to,
you know,
sponsor the technology
for me and to Gfsi me, uh,
in this development process.
Right. And you've got it
all work, like integrated.
So in your app you like put it up someone,
someone on the camera
and it actually will do.
Yeah.
So if you enroll a photo of someone and
then you can take a picture of them and
you'll recognize those people.
Right. That's pretty cool. Yeah.
Has your grandma seeing the APP? So
she has seen the APP, but you know,
she's in the literacy of the disease
and also she speaks Chinese. So, um,
that's one of the reasons why I want to,
you know,
get the app in multilingual because,
I don't want language to be
a barrier or a nice thing.
So getting into Spanish and Chinese
in the future, even more languages.
Great. So your earliest testers are
probably not going to be a grandma.
It's going to be people you go.
Yeah.
Hmm.
All right. So what, what kind of
developers do you want to work with?
I guess you'd be like the lead
developer and you're sort of a,
yeah, I really hope that
even if I expand the team,
I really want to be working in
the development because you know,
I still love to code and that's really
one of my greatest, greatest passions.
So I really, I'm looking at like, you
know, to collaborate with other people.
And make sure that this
gets into my goals. Hmm.
So would you say,
I mean there's a lot of programmers
and I think Google where we're sort of
filled with programmers who are like,
we grew up and we were
very much introverts.
We sat around in front of our computers
because we didn't necessarily like
people as much as we liked the computers.
But it seems like you're,
you're really across the board,
right? You're doing the business,
you're doing the UI design, you're
doing the, um, development, like what's,
what's your preference? What do you
like the best? Or is it everything?
Um, yeah, I really like everything.
Not just because like I like computer
science more or anything because I really,
my passion is really to use technology
and apply it to problems that I see in my
community. So it's not just, you know,
coding the APP, but it's also, you know,
reaching out to people and seeing,
you know,
what kind of things that they want to
see in such an app and know all around.
That's like really what
I really like enjoy.
Oh, what's, what's it like being
a 14 year old entrepreneur?
Um, I think definitely, you know,
age sometimes is a barrier because it's
hard for you to like go out and ask for
people's help and people just take your
seriously with your project if you're 14.
But you know,
I've been really lucky to meet people
on the way along the way who have been
really supportive of the APP and really
believed in my ability to get this to
completion.
It seems like Bill Gates takes
you seriously. Yeah. All right.
Is there any audience questions we
can take some of those or hold, oh,
we need to get a microphone.
Oh, recording catch sparks.
Who was it called? The other
question. Some microphone.
Go ahead, Hannah. Is it on? Yeah.
Um,
so first question,
I think one thanks for so much for coming
and sharing your story and your work
with us.
Um,
I think the thing that was really cool
about the APP and as a non super or not
technical person or less technical,
um,
really interesting how you
said like ultimately the,
the APP could be used for
research and data collection.
I'm curious about sort of what you said
on the front end though, that sort of,
there's some research or nascent research
showing that when you actually engage
with an Alzheimer's or dementia patient
in like a way other than just telling
them who it is or what data does that
that can actually help stave off or
improve their condition.
Could you talk a little more about that
and sort of the future for how you're
gonna build that into the APP or some
of the research you've seen with your
partners?
Yeah, definitely. Uh, so you know, the
part of the thing is that, you know,
repetition is like really
key for Alzheimer's patients.
So part of, you know, the,
the concept of,
you know,
seeing the updates and seeing the photos
again and again is really to refresh
their memory and let them see the same
people but in different contexts so that
they can kind of refresh
their memory on those people.
But not always just do the same
information over and over again.
It's you that's really like the
concept applies to every field.
Not only just engaging with friends and
family, but also seeing photos. Okay.
I have one more question
that's not app related,
but you've done so much in your 14
years from music to writing to attack.
I think, uh, I know this is being recorded
for Googlers and youtube audience, um,
you know more broadly,
but would love to hear some words of
wisdom from sort of how you've been able
like your own thoughts on your keys to
success or how you are able to do all
these really great, very
things and still, you know,
maintain your interest in writing and
sort of not be sort of singularly focused
but sort of life and task and focus
management advice would be appreciated.
Yeah, I mean like as I've know juggled
all of these different interests.
It's really actually how does the eye
I can intersect those because you know,
a law of what I do now is I write about,
you know,
my interest in coding or my interest
in helping other people with, um,
stemmed advocacy and getting girls
into stem. So I think that, you know,
one way to really get yourself in like so
many different fields as you know, how,
find some way to intersect
those two fields,
like writing about tech or you know,
doing music, writing about music.
I think that's like,
you know,
how I've been able to kind of grasp
a hold of all those different, uh,
interests at the same time.
Awesome. Thank you. Thank you.
Terrific question over
there. Yeah. Um, so yeah,
my question is around just what were some
of your biggest challenges and how did
you overcome them?
Yeah, so I think that, you know,
cause timeless is the first APP that
I've really seen from start to finish
developing it, getting the ideas and
then seeing it, you know, complete, uh,
I'm hoping this this year. And so, uh,
one of the biggest challenges, you know,
have been, you know, what is exactly the
process for this and a lot of it stuck.
I've been,
I've been learning to how to be really
eager about reaching out to my mentors
about. Absolutely. I think,
because you know, they are
the ones with the experience.
So I think that,
you know,
reaching out to those people and asking
all the questions that you have is
really important because you know,
someone out there has the answer.
Okay.
So your current study coating
when you were six. Yeah.
So on your resume does not mean you can
say you have eight years of programming
experience.
I guess.
I mean I,
when I first started I kind of started
with scratch and then I wasn't as into it
as when I actually picked it up back again
when I was around 10 and I, you know,
I actually got into and the social
entrepreneurship field and saw, you know,
really the impact that technology has
on people because before you know it
sideways like a game or like a tool
that I could just kind of create.
But you know,
I really saw the impact and the benefit
it can have on not only people that I
know,
people that are around the world.
So that's kind of how I
picked it up later on.
So you got it.
You started off with the,
the interest in actually
solving problems and you,
you taught yourself coding so
that you can solve the problems.
Yeah. So it was kind of like, you
know, how do I do the certain task?
Like how do I make the cat move
from here to here on scratch?
And I kinda like went from
there and just exploring.
And then it was when I was around 10
that actually found that drive to create
something.
I see.
Did you go straight from scratch to swift?
Uh, I actually went through
things like html, CSS, MIT,
app inventor,
and then I,
when I was around I think 10 or 11 I
went to his class at the flood are in
school for high school students to learn
how to do ios programming. And you know,
that's where I kind of, and the class
actually had a really big focus on,
you know, how can you use your
apps to help other people?
And I think that's really,
really inspired me.
Not only just technovation but seeing
going to that course and seeing, you know,
I can actually have an
impact using technology.
Wow. So what's, uh,
what's next? Is it, is it,
are you sticking primarily
with this one app?
Do you want to get it done or do you
have other ideas you're working on?
Yeah, I think my primary focus is this
app because I really want to see it,
you know, get out into the
world and see, um, you know,
patients who are going to
be benefiting from this.
But I'm definitely really interested
in the machine learning field and data
science.
It's one of the reasons why I'm working
on my lung cancer project for lung
cancer and CT scans with machine learning
because I really want to explore,
you know,
the intersection between technology and
health care and how machine learning is
really helping us in those fields.
Interesting. Any more questions?
Yes. Um, so I'm wondering is it working?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm wondering that how difficult it's
going to be to engage a new user into
using a timeless,
like somebody with alzheimers,
wouldn't they be likely to forget to
even use the APP in the first place?
How long would it take and what do you
plan on doing to keep them coming back?
And continuing to use the
APP for their benefit?
Yeah,
that's a great question.
I think that this is one of the reasons
why I made sure that the caregiver
played a really big role in
the app because you know,
everything is really between caregiver
and patient and a family and friend
relationships to make sure that those
are really hands on really close. And so,
you know, part of it is that,
you know, caregivers have, uh,
an administrator kind of role to make
sure the the patient has keep on,
keeps on using the APP,
keeps on engaging that family and friends
keep on engaging with the APP because
really it's, um, you
know, people, you know,
seeing more content coming in that really
engages people to keep on using it.
Okay. And for somebody,
for a family member,
would they have to install the full app
and log into the patient's account if
they wanted to share or
is that done separately?
So, uh, they would have
to download the APP,
but there are three sides that I will
integrate it into the same app so they can
register as a family and friend or,
and be invited by the caregiver
into the patient's, you know,
circle of friends and then they would
be able to share their photos through
their photos app in order to, you
know, let the patient see those photos.
Interesting. Thank you. Thank you. Okay.
Anybody else?
There's one, um, your body of work is
extremely impressive, so Kudos to you.
I was curious to know whether or not
your school is supportive and helping you
work on your app.
Like whether or not they've had any input,
whether or not they've helped you to
reach out to people and what education
goals are you looking at in the future?
Have you started,
you're not in high school yet, are
you? I just started high school. Okay.
Are you looking at any
particular colleges already?
A lot. Yeah. I'm haven't
really looked at colleges yet,
but it's definitely like I really want
to go into a computer science and uh,
you know, definitely looking at healthcare
and computer science and that's,
that's the field I really want
to go into in the future as well.
But in terms of my school, you know,
my school has been really supportive.
All of my endeavors in technology
especially, you know, with uh,
reaching out to people about
scholarships and contests, you know,
they have been really supportive of that
and pushing me to kind of go and push
my boundaries and see where
I can explore. Um, my school,
this is outside of school project, but my
school does teach, you know, basic, uh,
computer science. In seventh grade we
did some of that called processing.
It's like a very basic version of Java
that we use to learn computer sciences
integrating to our math class as well.
So the unit,
there's definitely a framework
for computer science at my school.
Okay.
Yeah, I have a question. Well,
thank you so much for coming.
I just want to say personally,
I've been so touched by
everything that you're doing.
I hadn't experienced of
Alzheimer's in my family.
And it's such a terrible disease.
So you're really bettering humankind
and that's something you should take to
heart. It's amazing. Um,
so my question for you is as we know
it's a progressing disease and it's
something that can start out a little
bit light and then get really terrible.
So in phase two are you thinking about
different ways to tailor the APP to the
different phases of the disease?
Yeah, it's definitely something that
I've been thankful about. You know,
how do I kind of personalize it to a
patient cause the disease affects everyone
differently.
And this is one of the reasons why I've
been networking with so many doctors
because there are so many ways in
different kinds of approaches that you can
take when making such an APP.
And you know,
things like integrating those mental
exercises into the APP or using
gamification is really trying
to make sure that, you know,
every aspect of the patient's life is
encompassed by the APP and any stage of
the disease.
Thank you.
Thank you. So you're working really
closely with caregivers like the house.
How much more work do you think needs
to go into the APP before you can do a
little bit of trial with them and actually
start getting the feedback directly?
Yeah,
I think it's mainly just finishing up
the development and the coding of the APP
for, I can actually release it because
you know, a lot of the framework is there.
A lot of the people that I know are there
to kind of get ready for the pilot was
actual patients.
So I think that it's really just finishing
coding it up and then releasing it
that I can start actually
soliciting feedback.
Is it in the APP store already or
it's not right now because I'm still
developing it, but it's going
to be there like mid year. Yeah.
So do you think that if you had enough
time you'd be able to do all the
necessary work to get the app finished
or are there things that you're missing
right now that you need help with? Um, I
think it's definitely just an issue of,
you know, time, because I'm
a full time student, so I,
that's one of the reasons
why I really want to.
And you build a team of developers so
I can code evolve this bus because it's
really a matter of,
you know,
getting people on this and developing it
together that will really speed up the
process. That makes sense.
So what is your, do you have,
do you have other friends that are
into this entrepreneurship or coding or
anything like that? Or is it kind
of lonely at the top right now?
I definitely do have friends
who are like into, you know,
the social justice and social
entrepreneurship. I'm actually at school,
I have a group of high
school friends who are, uh,
we're all working on this project
called food for thought. And it's a,
we're trying to build a platform for
people who get free or reduced price lunch
to kind of get Janae like kind of like
a go fund me school lunch to make sure
that they don't go into lunch debt.
Hmm. So we're working on that as well.
And you know,
that's also goes into living the
technological entrepreneurship and social
entrepreneurship field.
So I think that definitely getting more
people interested in exposing people at
my school to this kind of
work is really important.
Anybody else?
It's a cumbersome microphone.
Um,
you mentioned your current fundraising
model and how you were hoping to maybe
hire engineering resources first,
but as you look to Beta test the APP,
I was wondering if you were thinking
about partnering with scaled, um,
caregiver sources like
home instead or you know,
maybe multi touch points for people who
are working closely with Alzheimer's
patients at home?
Yeah, that's definitely something I've
been definitely working on. You know,
reaching out to people,
like the Alzheimer's Association has a
whole network of caregivers, you know,
trying to find those resources
to really get the word out there.
Okay,
so what can, what can we do to make
you more successful? What do you need?
I think definitely just
spreading awareness is, you know,
the biggest thing right
now because you know, the,
the APP is really dependent on people
knowing about this and people really
engaging with the APP.
So I think spreading awareness and making
sure that people who have Alzheimer's
are affected by Alzheimer's. You
know, know about this and you know,
get involved when this comes
out. All right. And the,
the Indiegogo page is under timeless.
Yes.
And I did a Google search for Indiegogo,
timeless earlier,
and there were two hits. There's
timeless, the movie and timeless,
the healthcare APP. You want the
second one? Um, all right. Well,
I think that that is a good place to stop.
All right.
So thank you again for coming.
Thank you so much.